that's the ideological point that this
is a new thing though right I mean
relatively speaking this this hard-nosed
stance from the left of the equality of
outcome and and the only reason why
there wouldn't be 50 percent women or 50
percent black or 50 percent any you just
pick any marginalized group the only
reason why wouldn't be even across the
board with all other races is because of
discrimination this is a fairly new
stance I mean there were there were
moments that were fairly well publicized
that I don't forget when Larry Summers
got fired from Harvard so Larry Summers
was the president of Harvard and he's a
famous economist and he gave a speech
for which he was fired there might be a
little more color as to why he was fired
I mean it was more fired because he he
wants the the wheels started to come off
he didn't he had alienated enough people
that he didn't have friends to kind of
prop him up but but the thing that
pulled the wheels off was that he gave a
speech and he said we know there are our
differences in in the the bell curves
that describe you know mathematical
aptitude between men and women and this
explains why there are many more
top-flight male mathematicians and
engineers than women and it's not that
they even it's not that the the means of
the the of the bell curves are different
so the means could be the same but there
could be more variants so that the tails
are thicker in the case of the male bit
bell curve so it's at the absolute ends
both at the low end and the high end you
have many more people so you know if
you're gonna ask you know what's the in
the same-size population how many people
do you have at the 99.999% aisle of
aptitude in math say it could be that
you have and there's a fair amount of
data to show this many more men at the
tails than women right and and that's
true for grandmasters in chess right
it's just the it's just this is not a
and it may be true for something like
you know playing pool you know I mean
they're they're just differences and
that may not be entirely environmental
almost certainly are not entirely
environmental that is one right it's a
big issue in the world of
cool men and women play separately and
there's no reason physically why they
should yeah it's not a strength game
right but women are allowed to play in
men's tournaments but they never win
gene B Lucas was a woman who's she was
like one of the only women ever compete
and beat men she's like an extreme
outlier and this was like I want to say
was in the late 70s or the 80s and other
than that there's been a few women that
have done well in tournaments but when
they come to major league professional
pool tournaments they're almost always
won by men and I'm when I say almost I
mean like 99.9% so there was a
Commonwealth Games didn't happening
because we it was just over the last
couple of weeks and there was a male to
female transgendered athlete in the
weightlifting category that's a whole
nother point participating in the
women's competition yes and the
Commonwealth Games at the time of her
joining hadn't yet put down a rule asked
the testosterone levels in the females
competing and so this male to female
transgendered person qualified in the
female games and was as you'd expect
winning in all of the games and was the
front-runner and destined to win the
competition as a male to female
transgendered person and the only reason
and it would have led to a huge crisis
in the Commonwealth Games because there
was some resistance to this notion and
of course the questions that arise is
this fair men are born naturally with
high levels of testosterone for example
the only reason it didn't lead to the
crunch time and that was the huge
scandal of of her winning is that she
injured herself in the competition and
while she accident yeah I saw that I can
expand on that a little bit because I've
actually gone through this extensively
because there was a woman who was used
to be a man was competing in mixed
martial arts against women and just
beating the [ __ ] out of them and I and I
was saying this is this is a mistake and
that you're you're looking at so whether
someone should be legally able to
identify as a woman betray themselves a
woman absolutely do you have the freedom
to become a woman
in quotes in our society yes but you
can't deny biological nature and there's
physiological advantages to the male
frame
there's its specifically when it comes
to combat sports that's my wheelhouse
I'm an expert I understand there's a
giant difference between the amount of
power that a man and a woman can
generate and if you're telling me that a
guy living thirty years of his life as a
man that's that's essentially like a
woman being on steroids for 30 years
then getting off and then having regular
women being forced to compete with her
and try to pretend this a level playing
field
it is not there's a difference in the
shape of the hips the size of the
shoulder the density of the bones the
size the fist weight that's a giant
factor and your ability to generate
power is the size of your fists it's
also an ethical problem it's not just a
competition here is he have girls
getting beaten up by someone who used to
be a man yes but people came down on me
harder than anything that I've ever
stood up for in my life never in my life
that I think there's gonna be a
situation when I said hey I don't think
the guy should be able to get his penis
removed and beat the [ __ ] out of women
and then people like you're out of line
but that's would happen this is a
conversation that I had with a woman
online this one one during this whole
thing she said she this person who had
turned into a woman has always been a
woman and I said but she was a man for
30 years she goes no she's always been a
woman I go even when she had sex with a
woman and fathered a kid and she says
yes even then I go well we're done yeah
because you're just talking nonsense
that's a technology coverings at the
facts as they are is that she had a male
physique this person was arguing with me
wants to claim this moral high ground of
being the most progressive and they're
always looking to step on top of anybody
who's less progressive than then and
complained and proclaimed superiority
and this is the ideological sport this
is the idea sport that that you see with
what people are playing just ping pong
with ideas they're not listening you you
need to listen to experts in in that
when you especially talk about martial
arts there's a the the difference is so
profound and the results are so critical
because you're talking about a sport
where the objective goal the goal is
clear it's very clear beat the [ __ ] out
of the other person in front of you
so anything that would give you an
advantage in beating the [ __ ] out of
that person should be really looked at
very carefully and not to thrown through
the the lens of this progressive
ideological filter that we're going
through right now cuz that's that's what
it is I mean that's how people are
looking at it it's with weightlifting as
well
when transgendered athletes going to
weightlifting competitions the male to
female transgender athletes are
overwhelmingly dominant I mean is this
is this a coincidence or it's no it's
someone who had [ __ ] testosterone
pumping through their system and a
y-chromosome their whole life and now
all of a sudden we're supposed to say no
she's a woman she's a she's dainty she's
got size 14 feet
she's got gorilla hands like the [ __ ]
he doing sir so I think as you said
earlier it's she is a woman but for the
purposes of competition yeah against
other women you know legally she's a
woman at that stage right if she goes
through that identity transition but I
think we have to recognize and I think
even many traditional feminists are
making this point you match to the anger
of the trans community they're saying
hold on your what you're doing in this
way is actually we fought so hard and so
long for these female spaces where we
have a space of our own and now people
that used to be men are coming into
those spaces is actually quite literally
beating the crap out of us yes faces yes
you know whether it's but in boxing
whether it's in weightlifting in martial
arts they are - by definition they're
dominating or this of course they are
for the reasons you've said experts that
they're calling upon or almost all
transition doctors surgeons or people
that have transitioned themselves when
they speak to actual board-certified
endocrinologist some of the only do it
off record but one of them forget her
name she was in one of the big mixed
martial arts publications Ramona cross
sick I believe is her name she's saying
no not only does it it it actually doing
this transition like from male to female
you're forcing your you're putting
estrogen into the system so the bone
density change that would ordinarily
take place if you remove someone's
testicles and stop it just the
production of testosterone estrogen
preserves bone density
so you actually retain
the male bone density there's so many
problems with this and that and that one
of the other things they say well oh the
Olympics the Olympics allow it the
Olympics are very ideologically based
there's not a whole lot of science to
this to this transition thing of
allowing male to female athletes to
compete in the Olympics and there's a
extreme amount of corruption in the
Olympics as it is with the IOC being in
bed with wada the world anti-doping
agency and the way they handle this
Russian scandal I mean this Russian
scandal that was highlighted in that
fantastic documentary Icarus yeah I was
looking crazy the Olympics are not to be
trusted that is a gigantic multi-billion
dollar business where the athletes get
paid zero money it is inherently corrupt
from the top down no doubt about it
so to call upon them is to see who
should be competing as a woman [ __ ] off
they're not the experts this is this is
not something that's been examined and
this is coming from someone who one of
my jobs is examining and commentating on
fights that is a big part of what I do
I understand fights and I know what it
looks like when a man's beating the [ __ ]
out of a woman and that's what it looked
like when this person was fighting women
it was there was a massive physical
advantage massive and not a secular
advantage what was the way you mention
something about the reaction that you
got to that what was the trouble you
gonna talk people were so mad at me I
mean it was just so many know that they
took my words out of context they quoted
all these different gender transition
doctors at saying that there's no
science behind this and the science
behind it being totally fair and totally
equal it's just not and people know it
everyone knows it they couldn't put
Chris cyborg against this guy and give
him a run for his money
wrong way classroom that's the other way
that's the other thing and we're dealing
with a similar situation like that in
Texas I don't know about the girl who
was she was born a girl she's
transitioning to a boy in high school
taking testosterone but in Texas they
only allow her to compete as a girl so
she's dominated the Texas State
wrestling championship two years in a
row and it's horrific because she's on
steroids she's on testosterone and they
Eugene out for this kind of stuff
doesn't matter because they're testing
chromosome option yes she's a woman she
was born a woman right she's born a girl
so because the fact that she's
transitioning to be a boy they don't
give a [ __ ] you're a woman you're not
gonna wrestle against men you're a girl
you're not gonna wrestle against boys
so they've allowed her under extreme
protest mitts terrible she wants to
compete or he I should say wants to
compete as a boy they won't let him they
say no you were born a girl you have to
compete as a girl so when he competes
everybody boos it's awesome it's [ __ ]
awful I mean it's it's it's really that
question for you that way around if it's
female to male transition somebody that
used to be a woman that transitions to a
man and wants to compete with the men
they don't have an advantage on if
they're louder and this advanced if they
win in that context they've actually
done really good yes right look women
can beat men yeah I mean it happens all
the time in jiu-jitsu there's especially
in jiu-jitsu in particular because it's
such a technique based art but it is
possible there's there's also a woman
named Jermaine jaronda me who's
world-class mixed martial artist who's
multiple time world Muay Thai champion
who fought a man and knocked him out
it's a crazy video real man KO time with
us straight right it's it is possible
for them to win if their skill level is
so far superior that it overcomes the
inherent strength advantages but a woman
- male transition would be at a severe
disadvantage against the natural man so
would you be so in that Texas case they
clearly have it wrong they should allow
they should allow him to compete with
yes and would you be whereas I can I
think all three of us probably
instinctively would resist the notion
that a female that a male to female
athlete competes with other females
because they'd have enough quad resist
that yes but would you be for a female
to male athlete competing with men yes
because I don't think there's no there's
no better but here's the problem and
again the consent is sort of running in
the other he is continually putting
herself or he's putting her right and I
weigh knowingly and I'm not opposed to a
woman fighting a man if she so chooses
like I'm not opposed to bull riding yeah
if you wanted I'm not you know lobbying
to get bull riding outlawed but if you
want to be so [ __ ] stupid that you
climb on top of a 2,000 pound angry
animal go for it yeah you should be able
do whatever you want I think you should
be able to jump out of fairly good air
on airplanes
want to parachute you should be able to
risk your life parachuting the
difference lies in just massive
advantages and that there's a massive
advantage in transitioning from male to
female female to male here's the other
problem female to male you have to take
testosterone you can't legally take
testosterone and compete it's been a
giant issue in mixed martial arts
because for the longest time there was a
loophole and the loophole was
testosterone therapy and they were
allowing testosterone replacement
therapy for male athletes that were
either older or it's it was a it was a
symptom of having pituitary gland
damaged which comes from head trauma
which come which means really
essentially your career should be over
yeah your your body's not producing
hormones correctly and that's a very
common issue with people that have been
in war people that have been blown up by
IEDs people that have been hit a lot
even soccer players a lot of times
there's show diminished levels of
testosterone and growth hormone because
of pituitary gland damage so you
wouldn't even allow that so a female to
male would be in a whole nother problem
in combat sports because it's not legal
for you to take testosterone and compete